[Music]
retired lieutenant general h.r mcmaster
served in the army for 34 years but is
perhaps best known publicly for his 13
months
as president trump's national security
advisor he's been in war zones and gone
head to head with foreign adversaries
mcmasters tells what he learned from all
those experiences in his new book
battlegrounds the fight to defend the
free world and general mcmaster joins
me now from the campus of stanford
university general good morning to you
many people have taken your book and
shaken it upside down hoping dirt falls
out but they have been
unable to find any so i will skip all
that and just cut to the substance an
issue that i know worries you and it
certainly worries me and that is
potential election chaos the fbi is
warning that foreign adversaries may
seek to exploit divisions post-election
and doubt in the process the president
has talked about doubting the process
hillary clinton has
has told joe biden not to concede if
it's messy to you sir
are you worried about what's going to
happen the day after
election day tony first thanks for the
opportunity to be with you
yes i am worried and and the story that
i tell on battlegrounds is is one of how
russia is trying to drag us down right
russia's not that strong
you know they're economies about the
size of texas they have some real
problems and deal with demographics the
collapse of oil prices and so forth and
putin's coming under more and more
pressure but what what putin's trying to
do is he's trying to be kind of the last
man standing and what he wants to do is
polarize us divide us on on the issues
that already divide our society issues
of race and gun control and
and immigration and pit us against each
other and a great way to do that
is to raise doubts about uh about our
our our democratic principles and
institutions and our processes and
especially the election so what do we do
i think for all americans you know we
have
we have to really be cognizant of this
danger tony
how do we how do we temper the situation
which is obviously volatile when you
have russia involved as you say
they are weak but people who are not
weak president trump
former uh secretary of state hillary
clinton they are also commenting on the
election and
fueling the idea that it's going to be
messy and potentially stolen one way or
the other
how do you quiet things when you have
our leaders involved in the fight
well that's a big problem i think all of
our leaders the president everyone you
know
vice president biden everybody i think
has to send a simple clear message to
the american people
that we can secure our election process
and i think tony the american people
ought to be proud of
of what our government has done i mean
under the trump administration
to secure elections after 2016.
as you recall there there's a lot of
progress made between then and 2018
the russians were in many ways foiled in
in in their effort
uh to raise doubts about the 2018
election and to
and to create another crisis of
confidence
some of those reforms involve standing
up new organizations to
you know to protect different
information election infrastructure
but then also our cyber capabilities are
much more agile now we can combine a
good
offense with a good defense but tony i
would just say to you and your
colleagues
i mean what you do as journalists is so
important because we need
authoritative sources of information now
more than ever
and it's in social media and the pseudo
media
where russia kind of has a field day
right they use this
to move us to extremes and and reduce
our confidence in who we are as
americans
yeah well i mean we've been telling
voters to be patient that this could
take some time to count all the votes
but
i'm curious what with your reaction our
job is made more difficult when you have
an exchange like the president had with
a reporter yesterday
he was asked could you commit to a
peaceful transfer of power now that is
conventionally known as a softball
question but the president did not say
of course i commit to that
he instead continued to undermine
confidence in the vote i'm curious
knowing what you know about russia and
foreign actors what was your reaction to
hearing the president say that
well it's one of disappointment i think
we we have to have confidence
in the system that our founders set up
and you know our founders were really
worried about what they called factions
what we now call
political parties and they had very much
in their minds the
the bloody experience of of the english
civil wars in the
in the 17th century and and many of our
founders didn't want parties to exist at
all and so i think it's it's really
important for us to have confidence in
the system they set up
and especially separation of powers
right we do have judicial review and i
know there are these
armies of lawyers from both parties
already out there
but we have to have confidence in the
checks and balances
that our founders set up general
mcmaster one of the remarkable things
about you is in addition to your your
career in the military you also have a
phd
from unc chapel hill and on top of all
that you have an extreme
nonpartisan position you in fact do not
vote sir and have not in your career
i am curious though now that you are
retired will you vote in 2020
well tony i'm having a discussion about
that with my family it's a big change
right i mean i what am i
saying when i was 17 years old you know
and uh
and and so i i really i'm trying to
figure out now you know what my role can
be here in my second
career and and how i'm going to
participate uh in in our democracy
what i really wanted to do with the book
and what i hope i can do in the
discussions
like this after uh you know after its
publication
is to help bring americans together
right as we're at each other's throats
these great challenges to our security
they're they're not going away
and in many ways the crises that we're
encountering today is coveted
general mcmaster has catalyzed catalyzed
these challenges
they're counting me off i will tell
people it's not a juicy read but as one
reviewer said it's a meaty read i will
agree with that
general master thank you very much we
hope you come back very important
conversation
hey thank you so much and the new book
is battlegrounds it is on sale
right now